este jogo é muito grande sou eu tenho
aqui chave da minha nova casa sejam
muito bem vindos a dar colômbia
e não só como vocês puderam ver esta
casa é muito linda ou só a sala tem seis
metros de altura dá pra fazer muita
coisa lá e ainda outro segredo desta
casa eu trouxe dois cinturões um deus é
o pior e o outro é o malandro é quieto
no meu limite e desde sempre me
acompanharam um tipo sempre tiveram
comigo fazer os vídeos então é assim faz
todo sentido estarem aqui comigo quero
muito que estejam aqui então já sabem no
canal deus vocês também vão poder ver
vídeos aqui na casa então acompanhei lá
e vamos apresentar a casa no bairro
testo espreguiçadeiras que ainda não
usei porque tenho medo por dia
outra coisa que eu gosto daqui do jardim
e campo de golfe
aí eu não sei se vocês vão achar
interessante mas eu gostava de fazer
alguns diriam que com gol procuro muita
coisa aqui em nome do gosto do estilo e
outra coisa que eu adoro que basta que o
sol muito forte e institucionais luiz
vou lançar um desafio e já vem gosta que
é uma melhora da acne se dirigir até lá
no fundo que o melhor missão cumprida
[Música]
a mulher e ponto frio a mulher me pronto
falei
esta zona é uma zona boa para convívio
depois do churrasco só pessoa ficar aqui
conquistada por um copo é tudo é
perfeito da lei é que mais à frente nós
temos esta lagoa às 11 horas o desafio
um desafio vamos passar além daquelas
pedras
é isso que dá uma olhada na panturrilha
a lei só tem lama de uma máquina não já
sujeito me procurando e não ter feito
isto só aqui temos uma mesa tempo aqui
mas lá para fora temos o nosso churrasco
falei pra você caro só agora aquilo aqui
dentro nós temos é preciso interior é
muito ruim neste momento ela está aqui
tão puxada formulado por aí
no fim do vídeo vou mudar falou gostaria
que esta tivesse atendimento continua
nós temos também um barco voltar pra
ficarmos aqui também especializado e e
beber um sumo assim a equipe só gostei
de tudo há que se fazer exercício físico
tem esta máquina é daquelas que vibra
assim em captar imagens fazendo
exercício físico ficou que já não
aguenta o principal já começou a mostrar
aqui a parte onde a magia vai acontecer
e ele estava quase tudo outras memórias
de tudo no quarto e que vai ser salva
direção ele está em algumas são olha que
eu pensei eu tenho as minhas coisinhas
que a utiliza um do be uma luta que vão
estado que possui um armário nós vamos
deixar as nossas camas de nossas coisas
de que tem muita coisa muito bravo muita
coisa que ainda também a comissão
ressalva tudo vai ficar muito louca
porque nós vamos por rádios daqui tudo
com muitas câmeras de vídeo é que vai
com ela e é bom agora eu vou fazer quase
tudo aqui então vai ser uma mistura de
solo e quem falou baixos muito lindos a
mais um bilhão
eu acho que se fosse um espaço muito bom
e que traz vocês uma sala de cinema nós
temos junto um cinema em casa 1 a 1 se
não é cinema de casa
o fracasso costa muito aqui nesta sala
de cinema méxico quer dizer que neste
quadro não deve ter estas ao então o que
eu vou fazer é culpa do texto a
porter.com martel vocês querem ver esse
vídeo cometa y comecei porque o grupo de
estudos vai pôr mais um passo óbvio que
nós vamos tratar não só é uma pequena
zona do euro um saque bem as minhas
netas tem muito bem que daqui mas depois
vocês vêem com mais calma aqui nesta
zona e não vou doar o que vai acontecer
mas vai ser uma coisa muito louca aqui
por trás de um estacionamento nós
arrumamos nossas casas mas faltou pensar
em aplicar neste treinamento para fazer
uma super pista do que encontrou como eu
quero fazer isso aqui é continuar é de
que os carros só para todos que traz com
ela e com rampas com tudo claro que isto
vai demorar algum tempo então com calma
nós vamos fazer as coisas mas como ipês
o que vocês acham que isto vai dar certo
acho que não vai querer que eu faço isso
mesmo tem para lá então todos mostraram
que esta casa foi você já tem sala de
edição o salão dos brinquedos do meu
quarto e 500 milhões concentradas na
bola em uma casa bem e que tem outra
casa também mexe é spice é que nossos 15
horas
nós temos nosso amigo eu acho que a zona
mais importante da casa que a nossa sala
é muito grande pois o look fique no time
de cima como camila silva outro
brasileiro que é melhor ficar embaixo
depois popular através do sul fato que
ir em cima do skate elétrico dar a volta
aqui depois montar uma bicicleta
olha olha só olha houve quem levasse
gigante fez gol e fui
vou tentar com isso acho que exporta
frutas
ai não aí não vou fazer postura gera
numa proteína ou que uma preta foi
quando uma mola de comida já que é
necessário é muito mal tem seis metros
que vou tentar lançar orange voltar a
apanhar muito arriscado para lá
[Música]
afinal não sou mesmo que eu vou arrumar
isso pra não estragar a casa aqui nesta
zona pessoal uma zona de jogos nós temos
aqui uma mesa de sinuca e que nós temos
nossas placas do ídolo olha do lar
frango do milhão é destaque do mundo com
cerca de 100 mil inscritos esta é minha
de 100 mil inscritos
e essa é do ppe 100 mil inscritos outra
coisa aqui na sala que o torne adoro
mesmo é um buraco nós temos aqui nessa
sala consegue ver quem está na piscina
lá embaixo e eu consiga andar aqui na
sala você também consegue ver é possível
que essa casa tem uma coisa muito boa
que é muito sociável tempo na cozinha
tem vista para a sala a sala tem vista
para a piscina e eu lá em cima tem mais
um andar
olha lá em cima é o quarto do pib uma
cueca e aqui em cima é o meu quarto e
sei que quando eu comprar uma cama e um
armário e essas coisas assim mais
básicas e vou colocar lá em baixo
consegue dormir lá embaixo mas
provisoriamente é que um duro ataque eo
novo nome dela não vai mais voar aqui na
casa muito em breve
é é que ele encontrou quando é muito
grande a gente passa de fãs e daqui de
cima também conseguimos ver a sala toda
olha aí
incrível muito grande o papa falou com
ela ok não vamos trocar seu pessoal
vocês vão ver isso aqui no canal deus
em princípio eu acho que vai ser hoje
então eu acho que já está quase tudo né
mas vamos dar mais uma voltinha lei mas
por aí vai lá pessoal e perdi a noite eu
vou cumprir a minha promessa de dar um
mergulho na piscina para você o primeiro
que de casas criar team impul sofria
[Aplausos]
primeiro vou tentar ir mais fundo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
em duas horas e três votos pela passagem
de destaque deste vídeo espero que vocês
tenham gostado que não viva ataque
online à nova casa aqui comigo como é
que confiei que quem vai até a próxima
[Aplausos]
[Música]